the Ramadan period where you're going to
be eating very early in the morning I
would recommend that you consider eating
the most nutrient-dense meets the the
the meats that actually will have the
most nutritional value for your body and
that's not muscle meat which is most
commonly consumed but that's organ meats
like liver especially liver is the most
nutrient dense meat there is there are
what I mean by nutrient dense there are
more vitamins and minerals and liver
than any other animal food any other
plant food for that matter the liver is
the richest food source of vitamin A
which is absolutely essential for the
health of our immune system and through
our eyes and our skin and for heart
health and the B complex family of
vitamins are our in liver liver is a
rich source of all of your your B
complex vitamins which are your energy
and anti-stress vitamins especially rich
in vitamin b12 and there's some vitamin
C and liver which of course vitamin C is
important for healing it's important for
cardiovascular and immune health and
every cell in the body needs vitamin C
and vitamin DS and the lever and vitamin
E and basically all of your essential
minerals are in liver livers of course a
especially rich source of iron but liver
is also uniquely rich in a mineral that
a lot of people don't know about called
phosphorus phosphorus is actually the
most important mineral for energy
production in the body and so organ
meats
generally speaking whether it's it's the
liver or the heart or the kidneys or the
brains organ meats are more nutrient
dense than muscle meat and so if you're
only going to be eating a small amount
of food and then going a long period of
time about 16 hours this time of the
year before you're going to be eating
again consider consider organ meats